Okay,
back live.
Hi.
Got about an hour to do a little bit of
RL right now.
A lot of our stuff is in a pretty good
spot at the moment, frankly.
So, I think it's mostly just going to be
um
between
improving the battle sim
and uh starting really on more drone
stuff.
You know, the one thing that still
bothers me
if I can do switch over to here. One
thing that still bothers me is the
neural MMO
result.
Wonder if I should just start like a
really long sweep on that.
cuz like on one hand like
this is the best policy we have, right?
The stuff that this thing can do is
pretty cool.
Is it like 640 billion steps worth of
training? Cool though, right?
We have not re-swept this since um
3 0.
That's kind of interesting, isn't it,
that we haven't rewed this since 3 0.
That's probably the only really main
thing that we need to do initially is
just see if that does anything right.
Some sort of very long sweep.
It is a just a very delayed difficult
signal problem, right?
Like your rewards are don't die and
level up, right?
This is a pretty good policy.
Didn't realize.
Like not perfect though.
Definitely not perfect.
Is there anything I'm doing weird with
the architecture?
I guess there is like um
there are kind of some granularity
issues with the obs.
It's going to be like 11 by 11ish by 59.
So, you can't really put it into a flat
policy.
how does this relate in complexity just
by like my own intuition how's this
relate in complexity to our other ends
more complex than everything Okay.
Hope your channel gets a surge of reach.
Thank you.
Welcome.
My uh my account on X is be is uh bigger
than my account on YouTube. There's like
some decent amount of reach there.
I mean, neural MMO is just a much harder
problem, isn't it? That what it boils
down to.
in Terraform is kind of tough, but also
Spencer engineered the heck out of it.
What's the difficulty of neural MMO,
right? It's like it probably is a order
of hundreds step problem.
No, that's like what is that like uh to
defeat that enemy there
like an order of maybe a hundred step
problem.
But you have to know what like a
low-level enemy means. But there is a
perception element to it.
I mean, we could um we could look at
that for a And
okay, so you get
terrain type
and you get season
Get item type.
You get to see
their level minus your level
get to see their HP
animation and direction.
These are not great.
There shouldn't be a huge difference
though.
Okay, we at least we found one thing
about neural MMO that could be messing
with stuff at least.
I mean, we can do that experiment and we
can also run a sweep, right? Those are
two things we can do,
of course, after uh we do the main
stuff.
We're seeing uh results here, right?
I'm just actually learning now.
thought about working on developing a
reinforced language model.
Uh the issue is that like language model
stuff just gets a thousand times more
expensive minimum.
just instantly
cuz it's slow.
I think unfortunately I have to move
this.
I have to move this sweep.
That's okay. Like we kind of expected
this.
Just do that sooner rather than uh than
later.
Okay, so that is set up now.
Uh, so we should be able to get this set
up on puffer box zero.
Hey, Pdubs. Long time no see. How's it
going, man?
Did you see uh 3?
We have some pretty cool RL tech now.
How you been?
Heck of a lot better now that the
release is done. There's some crazy busy
stuff.
Uh I am currently on a farm in Maryland.
This is the puffer training facility.
You can see we have servers for training
agents and we have gym equipment for
training me.
I haven't seen too much about Japa to be
honest. Don't follow a lot of robotics.
We're currently doing a little bit of
robotic stuff on here. Just trying to
see if we can chuck puffer li on things.
But yeah, I think the coolest thing
lately has been this. the fact that we
actually have like pretty darn good
agents that just play neural MMO and uh
we didn't really do any work on neural
MMO. It kind of just happened from our
latest release.
This thing is better that better at the
game than I am for sure.
I'll put this I'll leave this up right
here.
That there
then
tiny box.
Not this one.
Too many terminals.
This one.
How'd I end up in Maryland? I'm on my
family's farm here.
Kind of just we needed a spot to put all
the hardware and stuff and uh I don't
know, this kind of just worked out.
I will be spending some time in Palo
Alto. uh in actually just a few weeks.
That'll be cool. Um and then middle of
winter Florida and then rest of the time
building stuff out of here. Fun.
The only thing not fun about here is
that uh I've got all this cool gym
equipment and I've got a bad rotator
cuff and I've got a bad knee. So, I
can't really use all of it.
But, uh, I've gotten a lot of AI dev
done since I can't really do much
Are you going to be in Palo Alto? Going
to be in SF? I think I'm going to be
there
maybe from like the 16th or the 17th of
July until start of August just for a
few weeks. And then I'll be there after
RLC. See?
second half of July. Cool. Yeah, let's
meet up.
Be fun.
I imagine you've been working on some
cool stuff as well.
So, we point out that this agent at the
bottom left has been playing this entire
time and is still alive.
It is currently level seven combat,
level 11 forging. It has equipped a full
suit of armor, a tier 2 weapon,
and some other stuff as well. Know
what's going on with this buildax? Takes
forever.
Oh yeah, there was the one other thing I
wanted to fix while I'm at it here.
I'm quite happy that I no longer have to
do that.
You probably don't want me helping you
on your exams, even if I could.
I haven't done any coursework in quite a
long time.
Ironically, I don't think I could even
do an ML exam at this point.
Most of the stuff that is asked on them
are so freaking irrelevant, it's
hilarious.
You can ask me stuff if you want like if
you have questions.
my last module.
You know, I actually don't know a lot of
the reinforcement learning math because
it's all defined stupidly.
Like if you actually look at a lot of
the ways like RL is written down, none
of it makes any sense or has any
relevance to the way that we actually do
RL. There's like very very little
overlap
ask you about like tabular Q-learning
and crap.
You want to actually have reinforcement
learning that works,
check out all the stuff on puffer.ai.
It's a good place to learn things as
well.
Do learning in SARSA.
I literally Okay. Like I I vaguely like
Yes. Okay. action condition value
function yada yada take action and then
gives you what is it Q function it's
it's like an action condition value
function
it tells you the value if you take the
given action and then proceed according
to the optimal policy or whatever
I mean technically, yeah, Q-learning is
still kind of relevant because of off
policy
training still exists even though it's a
mess, but like
are just a really bad problem model for
RL in general.
like you it's just uh you're in a state
assume there's a transition function
that doesn't depend on time that takes
you to the next state
and uh it like makes sense for tabular
problems
and then like kind of all the RL
algorithms that are based on them kind
of throw that out the window
immediately.
I'll tell you one thing for sure. If I
had to uh put together a course on
reinforcement learning, it would not
look anything like uh any of the
reinforcement learning courses that
exist now.
Okay,
let's see if this does anything. Well,
obviously we won't know for like three
days, but
let's see if it at least runs.
Okay, cool. So, this will run. We'll see
if I if anything changes with terminals.
That'd be a pretty funny error if uh if
it did.
Would also tell us something. So,
Okay, I got about 20 minutes before I
got to run. Um, use a restroom real
quick and then we'll find a couple
things to do.
Ready them in method or they still teach
us.
Yep.
H a lot of like the grad course work
kind of just drove me nuts because like
it's so out of touch.
Can you see if you can get asteroids on
the site? Uh yes, let's do asteroids.
Actually, that's a perfect small thing
to do. Let me use the restroom real
quick and then I'll do that. Be right
back.
The asteroids policy looks kind of
ridiculous to stick it on the website.
I'd like to train something a bit better
first.
We have a PR on asteroids.
We have um merged. Okay.
Okay. Already merged.
Okay, this is what the asteroids looks
like.
it found the same weird policy. Then
there's probably something fundamental
that's a little screwy with the game.
Trying to see if there's like a control
difference.
Oh, I forgot about the spaceships.
I forgot that they're spaceships.
Okay. So, I mean that's
No UFOs. I forget if that's in the real
game like the original
What do Indians not sleep?
Leave, man.
I'm trying to see if there's anything
weird that um
cause this
Wait, what?
Why the hell did you bubble sort this,
man?
Yo, Wooden,
why would you not just call quicksort on
this?
That'll make it a heck of a lot faster.
I didn't know it existed.
Probably do that if Hang on. Is this
thing slow?
21% end time.
I don't know how I didn't see that.
That's silly.
I mean, I can't see any explanation
other than it's just a good strategy.
It's completely possible, I guess,
right?
I got to go in a few, but let me at
least try a couple things.
See
Maybe it's one of those things where it
like emerges later in training that you
can do a little bit better if you turn
or something. I don't know.
Okay, so the score actually keeps going
up. We see this.
This is what I was wondering about.
You see the policy keeps getting better.
so it's quite possible uh wouldn't you
just need to sweep it for longer.
There are also some fiddly sweep things
that can happen if it's like not ever
exploring longer uh experiments.
Yeah. So, there's additional stuff you
can configure for it. Buffer sweep is a
decent starting point.
There's some stuff you can configure for
it.
This is now what's that? 28.
So, we'll see if this is just a better
of the same thing or not.
H,
okay. It's not going in a fully straight
line. It turned from the start.
Oh, it doesn't understand screen wrap,
man. Because it has relative
coordinates. It doesn't understand
screen wrap. That's what's happening.
At least that's part of what's
happening.
Okay. Well, we can fix that for sure.
But I do have to run for meeting. That's
a starting point. Cool. This will be
very nice once we have it done to have
on the website. Um, let me check the
stream real quick.
Okay, so to the few folks watching here,
um, you're interested in all this stuff,
puffer.ai for all the reinforcement
learning things, start the repo helps us
out. It's free. Join Discord to get
involved with dev. I will be back
tomorrow and uh, we will probably be
continuing to work on either battle
simmer, robotics, maybe drone stuff.
We'll see. Anyways, thanks folks.